[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the privilege of introducing you to
jeremy lee quinn who is an investigative
photojournalist
from california welcome jeremy thanks
for having me
i appreciate it i'm uh really pleased to
talk to you because it turns out
that you have been deeply involved in
studying a phenomenon
of which many of us have become
fascinated or with which many of us have
become fascinated
so tell us i didn't know it and that's
that was the shock to me
is that i didn't know it was there i've
been a member of the media
for 17 years working mainstream
from new york to california
started my career out as a small market
reporter in west virginia
but i've always been aware of what i
thought were
talking points and i didn't understand
what was going on until i was on the
streets and that
that is what i realized is that there's
a big difference between
the reality we're getting from the
screen and the reality that's on the
street right
now and that's because there's not a lot
of people who are reporting
on the street and uh and i noticed it
right off uh first day i was out
in that weekend of may 30th may 31st
i was in santa monica california and i
went to support black lives matter
and protest and add my voice in santa
monica
and very quickly it turned out to be
something quite different than
i expected now so for six months
i've pursued this story and there have
been
lots of obstacles when it came to
getting
anybody to talk about it or deal with
the evidence on the street
honestly in a empirical discussion about
what is what the hell what the hell is
going on and i think a lot of people
across the country feel that way and and
that
and i'm not surprised that it hasn't
stopped i i kept saying i said it's not
going to end with the election
there's other stuff going on well in a
very meaningful way i would say
it didn't start with the george floyd
protests
either so i you tell me whether this is
what you see but
i've been living in the pacific
northwest now since 2002
and the there is a thread involved in
anarchism
that joined forces and caught fire
when the black lives matter protests
broke out this year but that thread is
far
from new and so the expectation
that immediate events are going to cause
it to settle down
seem far-fetched well it actually goes
back even as far as 1986 and 1987
when you talk about two currents of
anti-fascism
and anarchism and
you could look at each event and
separate it into an anti-fascist action
and an anarchist action for example
in portland just yesterday or well i
shouldn't date it because
but this week in portland they set up a
new autonomous zone
and they succeeded and that is an ana
that is an anarchist action in the sense
that it's insurrectionary
it is an insurrectionary insurrectionary
insurrectionary anarchist action i was
in
sacramento just last weekend
and it was an anti-fascist action in the
sense that they went
specifically to counter protest
which was really launch and attack which
was labeled as
community defense against
the make america great again the maga
normies really
that were at the sacramento capital but
they are aligned with the proud
boys and that gives enough significance
in the brad twitter
population to pitch it as community
defense if the proud boys are there
we have to shut it down we go where they
go
do not give them the space to organize
that's a credo that ties all the way
back to 1987
1986 in minneapolis of all places
so we're talking about a
multi-generation phenomenon here this is
likely not the same people
from 1986 who are involved in these
actions now especially given
uh how young so many of them seem to be
well you'd be surprised actually that
there is
multi-generational involvement and i
think that that's what people don't
understand is radical movements of
course go back to the 60s the
the folks who were teenagers in 1987
1986
they were mentored by the
you know the folks in the 60s so this
there are people who hold on to
insurrectionary radicalism
and pass it on to the younger generation
so much
so that the largest network out there
that's operating right now is called
torch
antifa and torch
isn't just burning everything to the
ground it also means passing the torch
to the next generation
and and this is all stuff that's
actually quite transparent so
if you're on the internet and you are on
twitter there are a couple of groups
that are being explicit
berkeley antifa sacramento antifa
especially this last week they were
extremely transparent about what they
were doing
how they were doing it and that they
were attacking first
so let's go back a second um i have been
wondering about
the overlap between the so-called
anti-fascist part of this
and the anarchist part and it's
confusing because
in some ways the anti-fascist part
makes some deliberate reference to
anarchism and keeps its distance it's
almost like it's modulating the
connection
and even the symbols seem to be uh
ambiguous so
in other words there are a lot of
anarchist a's
spray painted around portland but
they're also quite a number of antifa
a's
and the nature of spray paint is such
that you have to be paying very close
attention to
to register the distinction so what can
you tell us about it
well there are part of the
the confusion is no accident this is
shifting identities and affiliation
makes it
really difficult to even talk about or
even say who's out there
there's one thing you can say that they
will agree on because part of it is
the character assassination of you don't
know anything you don't know what you're
talking about this is a subculture you
do not belong to
even for folks like us like i'm a 2016
bernie voter i voted green party before
i'm not somebody who they like to
portray as soon as you hear a voice of
descent
that guy is alt-right that that guy is a
troll
from from the um alt-right and so forth
a white supremacist all these labels get
thrown around
to shut down the conversation before it
can happen
and the press understandably is
completely perplexed they didn't even
know what words to use and couldn't
agree on them
back in june and part of the
issue with that is of course the
president of the united states coming
out
and citing an incident in buffalo
where a senior citizen activist was
pushed down by the police and
and tweeting that he might be an antifa
operative
and when that happens all of a sudden
the discussion becomes scorched earth
you can't
you can't even bring up the word antifa
i couldn't use it for about four months
because i thought even in my head i
thought that's just a right wing talking
point
but when you google antifa 2017
you will see and a lot of publications
named
the washington post editorial board in
2017
condemned the tactics of actifa antifa
as helping the very hate that they won't
say they're shutting down the atlantic
the daily beast 2017. you can google
these publications we knew what this was
back then but something
shut us up between the end of 2017
and now in examining what these currents
of radicalism
anarchism and anti-fascism are and how
they work
side by side and that goes back actually
to the very beginning of the 20th
century and
a lot of the anarchists like to si site
1930
spain especially there's this affinity
toward
towards the uh the uh the anarchists
against franco
and they even used spanish words one in
the
in the scene in the anarchist scene
insurrecto is used for those who are the
insurrectionists
the insurrectionary anarchists now they
like to
when the new york times piece came out
that was uh
that cited my work and was talking about
insurrectionary anarchism
it was a huge gaslighting on twitter of
you don't know what you're talking about
and i i fielded contacts within
the movement who said yeah they're
they're insurrectos
that's what we that's what you know
that's what we call ourselves
and people who are aligned with that
with insurrectionary anarchism
since 1987 you've had fights
in the skid hang skid head gang scene
between
uh anti-racist skinheads and neo-nazi
skinheads that's when the anti-fascism
began
but along with it came the anarchism
identification the insurrectionist
identification
and it all begins in minneapolis
actually of all places
all right well we'll come back to that
in a in a second um
i i do want to highlight this this point
that you make
about the fact that there is this
barrage of arguments that you will face
if you attempt to use these terms and it
doesn't matter whether you're using them
correctly or not
the response is always the same and i
noticed this
when uh evergreen broke down
uh on the basis of an anarchist plan it
was clearly anarchist in the in the
literal sense of the term
and at the point that i alleged that
what had happened was that the
campus had engaged in experiments in
anarchy i was accused
of not knowing what i was talking about
of mistaking anarchy for mayhem
or chaos and that just simply wasn't the
case
now there was mayhem and chaos but the
point is
what caused it was anarchism right
they stood down the police and they
allowed the
protesters to take over the role of
policing and it
went very predictably but in any case
everyone who engages these terms ought
to simply expect that no matter how
correctly they use them they will be
told they don't know what they're
talking about
well i think you can use insurrectionist
because
that's what they refer to themselves
collectively as is is it's first of all
it's revolutionary politics
revolutionary politics dates back to the
60s they will admit to that
uh radicalism you could use but i i i
don't i think they speak poorly for
radicals quite frankly
or and even anarchists and that's where
you get into the
to the issue classical anarchism and
anarchism is a personal philosophy of
individual freedoms is a profound and
profoundly american
in the sense that henry david thoreau
wrote civil disobedience and
we have a profound tradition of peaceful
anarchism anarcho-pacifism
and that of course with mlk and gandhi
that's what i was raised on it my folks
met at uc berkeley
in the 60s and so i'm raised with this
anarcho-pacifistic
background but the
insurrectionary anarchists have pitted
themselves
since the 90s against anybody
who is preaching anarcho-pacifism as
peace police that you are aligned with a
state
and you are an appeaser to the state and
therefore you are
even more dangerous than the police
itself it's one of the arguments
that is made uh you know i don't even
want to mention some of
the publications because the ones that
are the most intolerant of any view
besides their own happen to be the most
influential right now
they catch the most fire and you see
that being enacted on the streets
when with the idea of diversity of
tactics
and there's no such thing as a um
that as a bad protester that that
we will not please each other we will
accept all tactics
and under that credo unfortunately it's
the most violent and most uh
ambitiously violent i should say that
takes the day
and has far more resounding
effects than we realize because then we
can't even talk we can't even discuss
or point out where our possible flaws
are within a movement and this is
something that's being debated within
the insurrectionary anarchist community
itself
you have different types of anarchism
you have red and
red anarchism is social revolutionary
and my problem with it is that it's also
social authoritarian when you go into
the streets
it's the social authoritarianism of you
shall not film
unless we approve you and two
reporters from a local station in
portland were physically ejected
from the new autonomous zone in portland
and just
the other day and there's proof of that
on twitter and just how
how the her the hive will surround
somebody that doesn't belong
and bam it's an umbrella's in your face
it's you don't belong here get get the
[ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out you know it's in your
face and uh uh
i've seen a lot of it from coast to
coast from from
portland to dc and
the san francisco bay area is where i've
been mostly
because it's where i'm from and berkeley
antifa
and sacramento antifa have made no bones
about
what see the freedom of this is they
actually use the word antifa in their
name
so so i you can't get dinged when
finally
they on their twitter accounts are
admitting to what they're doing then you
can't get dinged on that
but as far as the the scene
insurrectionist
or insurrectionism under anarchism is
is accurate but there are people who
consider themselves classical anarchists
or even
armchair anarchists or anarchists that
don't leave their computer or don't
that have read everything are
intellectual anarchists and
academic anarchists and so you get all
of your
feel your you have to feel all of these
objections
all over the left part of the political
spectrum
just for trying to discuss it and
disclaimer after disclaimer uh
i have to put in constantly saying look
i'm not trying to go against anybody
here i'm trying to understand what i'm
just trying to have a conversation about
what's happening
you're being a journalist you're trying
to report what's actually taking place
and
uh you're facing these arguments which i
must say i've been
familiar with since since occupy
um i do want to highlight you mentioned
diversity of tactics i was just about to
mention it myself it's one of these
phrases that the first time you hear it
you don't quite get the full
significance of what's being said but
the idea that somehow in this space
any attack on what is loosely understood
to be the enemy is considered valid
no matter how dangerous or immoral
it might be understood to be in another
context and
what that means is that the movement on
the one hand
takes no responsibility for the sum
total of what is done
under its banner and at another level
is like a bad brain brainstorming
session
where no idea is too dumb or too wrong
to find itself brought into the world
in physical form and so you know i'm
we are always facing this question of
why are you allowed to engage in
violence
against a court house or people
defending it right why are you able why
are you allowed to do this
and the answer is well we're mostly not
doing that well
what is mostly not doing that you know
even
mean it's obviously a preposterous claim
at some level if you're participating
in a protest that you know full well
sometime around 11 o'clock is going to
start
attacking a courthouse with explosives
that in some sense you're taking
responsibility for that
even if you don't recognize it and at
some level we have to hold you
responsible
for um for joining a movement that
recognizes no limits on
its legitimate action is that unfair
they know it they laugh about it on
twitter quite openly
the other thing that i have is various
twitter accounts where i'm
i connected and there was a movement of
no comrades under a certain number and
they wanted to boost comrades so i just
jumped on twitter
got a bunch of comrades and i could i
could see
that the jokes and and they laughed that
we're even having this conversation
in regards in regards to
uh what is right and what is wrong
because the whole system is wrong
so so if you can laugh at us for even
breaching the conversation
then it's it's you know it's part of the
subculture well laughing at us is one of
the one things that they have right
right we are we are far too slow to
catch up to what this is and what it
wants and to simply say no
you're not entitled to destroy uh our
mechanism of governance because you have
some utopian notion that if we can just
get rid of it things will be better
right that's not your right you don't
have the right to chase people you know
to wake them
in the middle of the night in their
homes and harass them for
crimes that they have not committed this
is not your right and we have to say no
but at some level
we are you know we're just really late
to the party
discussing what is actually uh being
contemplated
you know my dad always says to me says
you know we on the left we just have
the hardest time saying no why can't we
say no
to certain things and
the first month that i was out there i
said
look i just want to give disclaimer
after disclaimer i
i switched my profile pictures to all
black
i i did everything i i support this i
know we need
radical change i know we do but i don't
know that this is
if we don't talk about what's going on
and how we're doing it
as part of the public conversation then
not only are we just not saying no we're
not even looking
right yeah i mean what i've been saying
for years now
is that we absolutely need radical
change and we can't afford revolution
radical change without revolution or
revolutionary change without revolution
is
is basically where i think we have to go
just simply to survive but the point is
even that gets me tarred as some kind of
a right
winger in this group even the
recognition
that radical change is necessary for us
to survive
is simply too tame it is not uh
destructive enough to be credible well
yeah you're with what is called a
reformist
and ref being a reformer when it comes
to police
or government or the entire nation
is is off the table with this current
movement
and they've been able to spin that but
it
how long is it going to carry on there
are people that are really dedicated in
specific
geographical areas in this country and
that's what what i think
people don't understand and why it's
been so hard the national media has
hasn't even
touched it a little on the right but
with
all these different misunderstandings
and propagandizing
in terms of their political viewpoint
but
there's vast regional and this is this
is a this is
two dozen local stories it's not one big
national story
the scene in portland though they
communicate with the bay area
it's still a very different animal
washington dc
as well minneapolis those are the four
sort of nexus points across the country
and it's
it's no accident again it has to do with
history and how these
as one anarchist who contacted me
told me he said what people don't
understand is it seems new
it's new to you but it's not this is 33
years
of framework organizing and
what is now known as an antifa
in its complete identities anti-fascist
action
but it's also anarchist anti-fascist
anti-fascist action
anti-fascist action was called
anti-racist action
in the united states starting in 1987
and
in minneapolis a group of anti-racist
skinheads called the baldies
wanted to expand into a network that was
nationwide
because everybody was dealing with the
same problem which was ethnonationalist
actual uh neo-nazis
called the white knights in minneapolis
that was the first
to arise and i have discussions with uh
one of the original members of
of the baldies and uh another wants to
wants nobody to talk to me at all so it
there's there's
uh the baldies just for uh my
clarification the baldies were the
anti-racist
skinheads is this right correct okay
they were a multi-ethnic
group in minneapolis that rose up within
the white knights and the white knights
are connected to the clan presumably
yeah well so they were um basically
neo-nazis
and there's clan affiliation metzger
this guy who recently died
was a sort of old-school neo-nazi that
would
recruit young people and so the youth
scene
especially around the pump the punk
scene and
and concerts and so forth was very very
much enveloped by the struggle of
you're either this or that there were
neo-nazis and then there were the anti
the ara the anti-racist
action skin had said look
you you're with us or you're against us
these are
this is the next this is an existential
threat on our buses
at our clubs and they would go up to
folks who were
neo-nazis and say look if we see you if
you're a neo-nazi next time we see we
see you
you know it's over just be just be aware
and so so they
see that as one of the sort of
nascent victories for the cause because
they did
put down actual neo-nazis and stopped
them
from taking the streets of minneapolis
in the late 80s that extended into the
90s
and the organization broke up
in the late 90s but then that framework
still stays intact those relationships
and with the rise of twitter in the
in the internet you had rose antifa in
the city of portland
being formed in 2007 now in between you
have
probably the most dramatic anarchist
action
which takes place at the wto and that's
folks from eugene
who took on the black bloc tactics and
the black block tactic
at first was widely used in the green
anarchism scene as well i even when i
covered tree sitters at uc berkeley back
in the 2000s
one of the guys who was sort of you know
going from tree to tree uh was in black
block
and they uh they worked on a similar
ideological and tactical framework the
black bloc
by the way comes from germany and that
first was put in practice in 1987
as well when reagan visited west berlin
and there were black bloc
riots and those anarchists according to
one of my sources
actually came to the united states
after that and met with anti-racist
action
and anarchists that were
insurrectionists and
gave a workshop on black bloc technique
and their first stop
was minneapolis their second stop was
portland
interesting now there's something here i
want to capture and i don't know how to
do it
i i've i've experienced it i've seen it
i've thought a great deal about it but
it does not
lend itself to a proper description and
it strikes me that the reason
is because actually this anarchism stuff
is a bit deeper than most people would
imagine
there's something about the way that it
spreads
that is
i think just matter of fact contagious
and the way that it you know i hate to
use the
language of disease because that's
something that people do
when they are setting up other humans
for for
violence but that's not my point here my
point here is really
that there is something about this that
takes over
things it drives away anything that will
hold its ground
it captures anything that doesn't know
how to defend its perspective and so
on the one hand i see anarchists having
become a problem
for example for chris hedges right chris
hedges would also be dismissed as a
reformer
though uh like me chris hedges is quite
clear about the degree to which
there are structural problems in
civilization
that need to be addressed um
[Music]
let's just say i don't think reformer is
a proper
label for him or for me or anybody else
who recognizes the full scope
of the problem that civilization has in
the 21st century
likewise uh derek jensen is
challenged by black bloc anarchists um
for various positions for example on the
meaning of biological sex
so there's a way in which it has an
immune system
that does not listen to voices that are
sympathetic to the idea that there is a
problem when those voices say anarchism
is not the solution
right and at the same time any movement
that is in the neighborhood of the left
gets taken over and co-opted so
occupy for example started out as a
protest
against uh financial
recklessness in 2008 and government
bailouts
that caused it to be amplified and
that was how it began but then what
people on the outside who weren't
participating did not realize was that
anarchism infused it very quickly
and took it over and turned its message
meaningless so
um to the extent that it was a very
hopeful moment in which the world might
have woken up to some shenanigans
that were actually uh decreasing the
well-being of
most americans for example and people
across the world
instead what they got was the impression
that occupy was
itself just simply a bunch of juvenile
utopians who didn't know what they
wanted
yeah well anarchism itself and we have
to clarify
you know of course i'm going to get
nailed anyway but insurrectionary
anarchism as opposed to anarchism in
general
anarchism has so many dif it's very
very amendable two different
struggles and ideologies so you have a
narco communists you have
people who are uh who are
anarcho-primitivists
who are green anarchists that uh have
more
you have even people who are more narco
spiritualists that
use it as a as a personal philosophy
which is more of how i
see anarchism in regards to my own
anarcho-pacifism so
it can be it can be used as
individual libertarianism is is another
we do have
folks who are you know the boogaloo is a
classic example of this
folks that embrace an enarco perspective
that are actually from the
r what we would consider to be the right
of the political spectrum the press is
completely mystified by this i
i think the libertarian uh press has
figured it out
but but to just say all boogaloo are far
right or we keep
saying anybody with a gun is far right
and so forth it's a lot more complicated
than that and anarchism is just very
it can be it can be passed around
because the good
part of it is about individual freedom
and individual accountability so the old
school anarchist that i've had
conversations with and i've i've
interviewed
some uh for my podcast as well and
uh well one of them a classical
anarchist up in vancouver who was
who was one of the founders of occupy
told me uh
in his in his accent he said if i hate
it when people
talk about categories it makes me want
to grab my revolver
and uh so there's this classical
romanticism
about being a pure anarchist
but in today's spots to society
especially with
twitter and facebook groups and
subgroups you have
all these it can be abbreviated too n a
n
com an arc of comics and prim and arco
primitivist
so it's it's it's it is very flexible
and as a twitter a twitter identity
um we see ideas
and identifications being passed along
now the question is well what do you do
with it
what do you do with your anarchism and
i would say that after months and months
of being embedded and at these marches
and seeing how things develop and how
people are communicating how it's
playing and we haven't even talked about
the social justice movement at all
and how it's worked its way it has been
compatible uh or in my view not
compatible with that
but the what i've come to
to understand is that there's a specific
authoritarianism the social
authoritarianism that we're witnessing
with the insurrectives with the
insurrectionists and
that's everything from the umbrella
being
shoved in your face if you try to film
to
well i'll put it this way in sacramento
when we were marching this last weekend
there was a volley with the police it
starts off with a shield
push uh against the police and the
the piece of propaganda that they like
to say see look the police has their
they have their backs to the proud boys
and to the maga people look
look like it's this offense no no the
cops in the clan go hand in hand
and and it's like well no you're
attacking them
and you're the ones attacking the
problems you're just standing there this
is sacramento i'm not going to talk
speak on
disclaimer again i'm not speaking on
behalf of every problem i'm saying what
i saw in sacramento
what i've seen in the san francisco bay
area from the
antifa sacramento and berkeley antifa
factions in the limited time
that i have been with them because this
has been going on since 2016
in the bay area right after trump was
elected
was when the first riot started in the
bay area
so that was november you know
of uh i'm losing a 2016 right yeah and
so these conflicts moved into the
university at uc berkeley of course as
we all know
with the free speech right wing
movement of coming into the university
and those being shut down by black bloc
practitioners and again black bloc we i
have to define because they ding you on
this all the time that black bloc
is a tactic so it's easily used and
quite frankly we have to expect that
every technique that we have let slide
for the last six months is now being
passed to
the other side of the political spectrum
and i can get into that
how i've seen guy fox masks and people
dressed in black
now at stop the steel protests so
we've those tactics are out of the bag
now and we've let them
slide as a society this is not a right
wing or a left-wing thing
this is as a society do we agree on what
is
acceptable to allow without saying
anything and that's the issues that
we're not talking about so
when i'm in sacramento and i see this
happen
and it's it's it's not either not
reported all
or or misreported or focused the local
affiliates one of them focused on a
proud boy who was in a santa suit
who sprayed mace and had a bowie knife
and he pulled it out
and that was their headline for the bait
for abc in the bay area
well what about the do we not are we not
going to tell the rest
of the story that there was an attack no
they did it's what we call burying and
burying the lead and we're getting
really good at it on the left right now
is that all that information is at the
end where
where very few people dare who attention
spans dare
their tread so so at the front we're
putting this
this stuff that is socially okay
for me to talk about and then the more
difficult stuff
at that abc bay area article is at the
very bottom
which is that the uh the black bloc
then left the capital and systematically
destroyed cars but bashed out windows
uh kicked in review mirrors and slashed
tires to
any car that had an american flag or
a trump sticker or anything that that
was remotely
right-wing and it was a i was there i
have video of this
um i should mention publicreport.org
is the is the uh site that i run in
which i
i from a non-partisan empirical
just scientific view i just want to take
a look at what's happening
so even though i've i've uttered a few
opinions of my own
on this cast on the actual site and less
noted i am just taking the evidence and
trying to tell people from
from the street what i have witnessed uh
and it's all evidence-based you'll see
photos and video and i have the video of
sacramento i haven't released it yet in
which
i was in the black block and they
admitted though
uh berkeley antifa sacramento antifa
they said
they have pictures of the cars on their
twitter feed and they and they say this
is what we did this was a necessary act
of community defense
against the proud boys who have
terrorized us
that's their position i've asked them to
to
provide evidence of that position i i
haven't heard back yet
all right so there are a couple things
that we need to go back and just
collect here because really you know
most of my audience will have some
familiarity
with anarchism and antifa but there's a
lot of what you're saying that will be
mysterious i have the sense
so on the one hand we have
tactics right so black block is a tactic
right it's a tactic that
obscures it both creates an identity
but that identity is not individual
right so if you are looking at a bunch
of people who are dressed in black or
obscuring their faces
they largely know who each other are
it is hard for those on the outside
including the police to identify them
individually which actually plays into
some of what happened here in portland
where apparently protesters were taken
off the streets in order to figure out
who they were before they were released
as federal indictments were
sought so it was necessary to establish
their identity
because they were obscuring it but
anybody can use that tactic right if
you're out to violate the law
in pursuit of a cause then that tactic
is
one you might avail yourself of and
actually our domestic black bloc
as i understand it picked up that tactic
from europeans am i correct
correct it was first used in germany in
west berlin
all right so we have all of these
tactics and we have all of these
factions
of uh anti-fascists and anarchists
that believe in different future worlds
but in some sense
what they share is a belief that this
world has to be torn down
in order to get where we're going now
they regard people like me
who would tell them actually game
theoretically what you're saying makes
no sense
we are reformers therefore easily
dismissed even if what we're saying is
true
we're going to have to destroy
civilization to discover the truth of it
even though it's
perfectly obvious if you uh understand
the dynamics
but nonetheless the problem is that
you have an alignment of those who would
tear down
civilization as it stands in pursuit of
something that cannot happen
and that can even align people you know
we have blm
which has um deep marxist roots
marxism is not anarchism right
but marxists and anarchists can team up
on the project of destroying
civilization in order to replace it with
something and then they will fight over
whether or not
it is to be replaced with some
completely horizontal
ground up phenomenon or some top-down
marxist phenomenon
and in in effect those of us on the
outside of this movement have to
understand
that what we are facing is a temporary
agreement about destruction
right and then a massive disagreement
about what's on the other side and that
frankly none of the people
who are making these arguments are in a
position to understand how you would
build something different than the
society we have
never mind how hard it would be to build
something that worked better
than what we've got right in other words
we have something that has the basic
functionality
and you can dismiss the idea of changing
it as simple reform and therefore
not good enough but the chances you'll
build something much much worse
are spectacular so we who are trying to
figure out how to
how seriously to take this have to
recognize that the only thing that this
amorphous multi-tactical phenomenon
agrees on
is destroying what works right and then
they have a big disagreement about what
comes next
right they agree on no compromise that's
that's the
that's what's agreed on right now as far
as what comes next that was
brought up in the times article where
where the woman who i had interviewed me
asked
they seem very good very very good at
tearing things down the question is what
they intend to build in its place
and there's there's little agreement on
that i would say
but uh that's a that's a that's a tough
one
i but the idea that the whole system has
to be thrown out because it's
colonialist and it's
uh oppressive uh i
it's it's a very narrow understand
standing and you know of course a lot of
the
people that i've been out on the street
with are very young and
up in portland as young as uh
you know 13 or 14 when i was in new york
in rochester i came late to a protest
and what was remarkable
rochester new york when it was activated
was they had all the outside trappings
of portland
all the tactics had gone viral they had
a shield line check
gas masks check everybody had helmets uh
umbrellas skateboards they had
everything and this kid is coming by on
a skateboard and i was like
i asked him hey has the protest finished
or started what's what's the situation
he was like
oh yeah we just uh we just painted
murderers on the
on the uh asphalt and but it's still
going and gone and he was literally like
12 years old on a on a skateboard it's
it's getting very young and
that's not that's by design the
anti-racist action
uh insurrectives the sort of old-school
guard
that is uh contemporary
to you know those who are teenagers in
the 80s
they actually spoke in lansing michigan
or no ann arbor
sorry it was in ann arbor and they told
a group
that you should you need to go to the
high schools
flyer the high schools is the exact
quote
because high school kids have this
totally different it's one thing to work
with college
get to the high schools was their advice
that's 2017
in the during post charlottesville
richard spencer
an actual white nationalist is is at
work doing his thing
and that was their advice to
anti-fascist organizers
at that time and uh and we see that
there is at the bellingham youth
liberation
front page they've tweeted a picture of
them flyering
bellingham high school and their flyer
says are you radical are you under the
age of 25
and it has the communist sickle on it
and the anarchist logo
and it says join the youth liberation
front who is one of the biggest actors
of course in your area in the pacific
northwest and now has chapters
down by us in the bay area there's now
norcal
youth liberation front and there's
too much of a name check but there are a
lot of organizations and that's what
people
also need to understand is when
sacramento
antifa on their blog admitted to what
they did which was not just
breaking out a bunch of cars but they
actually beat up
a young couple and that was similar to
what i saw on october the 17th
when magga normies were
beaten up unilaterally it was unilateral
attack without defense
uh but they admit to this uh on their on
their blog
as well that uh that this is what
they're doing
um but but they
they're starting young and that's that's
the strategy it's by design
so let me ask you something about that
um i'm trying to understand
uh what i'm seeing with respect to who
is being arrested and we have a very
interesting phenomenon here in portland
which i'm sure you know about and i'm
sure is not unique
where there is a bail fund people who
wish to signal
their um you know their uh credibility
on the left
donate to a bail fund that then bails
people out who've been arrested for
uh for violence or property damage or
whatever
and that means that their
mugshots are available
and um it's actually quite disturbing
now i'm hesitant
to infer too much because i would
imagine that if you've been out
protesting and
maybe you've been tear gassed and you're
then photographed after you've been
arrested it's probably not the best
photograph ever taken of you
but it's hard to avoid the impression
that there might be something
marginal about the people who are
getting arrested in other words that the
movement may have captured the attention
of people
who aren't particularly good at
limiting themselves and so i'm wondering
about
flyering the high schools in every high
school there are
violent uncontrollable kids who cause
trouble if you present them a
cause which makes their
natural tendency to do harm
to break rules for its own sake and if
you say actually you're doing this for a
good
cause it strikes me that it's going to
pick up a lot of those people who would
be doing the same stuff anyway
just because they bridle against the
rules
and they will do it under this flag and
so we when we encounter
these very young people engaged in
violent destructive behavior
and we try to understand it through an
ideological lens of anarchism and
you know a resentment of colonialism or
whatever we're sort of missing the point
which is
they're destined to be two categories
one category is people who have been
persuaded of something
and are acting this way because they
think that it uh
is the solution to a problem that they
have come to understand is important now
they're still
wrong right this behavior is destructive
and as we were just talking about
it's not going to lead anywhere there's
not even agreement on where it should
lead
but nonetheless an ideological person is
very different from somebody
who is dysregulated and violent and
destructive and has signed on because
this
gives a kind of pseudo-coherence to what
they're doing
so do you see both of those things on
the ground
well you know that the generational
gap is interesting because only
in san francisco have i seen the old
guard
in pictures i've seen some of the old
guard insurrectives
post pictures that i identify them at
the back of the crowd
but in sakura in sacramento san
francisco on
october the 17th they actually followed
two
older generation folks who were
mentoring
these young kids who were teenagers so
and they looked twice their side
this the guy was it was extremely he was
very tall
and he had an anarchist tattoo on his
uh right here and there was another
fellow who had a sharp jacket
sharp is one of the original anti-racist
organizations skinheads against racial
prejudice and these two
were had a flock of young teenagers who
were black bloc
in black black i saw them go after
a young man it was an asian guy who came
up and he was he was filming
uh what was going on and so these kids
chasing white and then they just kept
chasing it and they chased him all the
way down a block
the only people that were following were
me and these two older guys
to see what would happen well eventually
the
the uh the perp who had taken a picture
was uh hid behind the police and they
were like you know [ __ ] you you know
yeah you need that you need the pigs and
all this stuff and then they come back
and the younger guy says to the older
the older guy man
i was about to kick him and and went to
the [ __ ] pigs
and so there there's this there's this
mentorship
that i think people don't see and it's
important to understand that if
old the idea itself the ideas
are considered to be so pure and so
righteous
that they will be past generation to
generation and
that it's when
when there are so many in when it's
fertile ground
and so so so many people are
disenfranchised or just disenchanted
or just young
there's a lot to gravitate towards
especially when you have older folks
wanting to connect you to a tradition of
a righteous tradition and that's what
people don't see is that there's a
history here
there are organizational elders
and then there are young people who are
just doing their own thing
and that's what we see in portland too
is that the youth
are kind of saying to everybody else
we're
we're doing this on our own in some
cases because again you have different
factions in portland
uh but the young people are very
independent at least they say that they
are on
twitter there there was a split i
mentioned to you on october sorry
august the 6th the a bunch of
anarchist instructionary anarchist
groups went
separate from blm and robert evans just
one of the reporters
actually tweeted the flyer and said this
is the first time that they're going to
be going out
on their own well well we have seen some
divisions so much so that we haven't
even talked about black lives matter
uh so far in this podcast and i don't
even know that the
that the three women who started black
lives matter
if they really understand the level of
tactical coordination that's on the
street in this
other direction because the three women
who started black lives matter who are
part of black lives matter global
are very accomplished activists who are
working in a very public and
capitalistic forum
in in a sense and it's pulling in all
these endorsements and all this money
but these other groups that are on the
ground are
of a very different world and ideology
so much so that there's been a schism in
black lives matter in the sense that
local chapters that are the fro say
they're the front lines
issued a statement recently in which
they said they
objected to one of the three being
appointed the executive leader without
any sort of democratic process and
they're asking about
you know funding and allocations of
funds
you know so there's all these divisions
even with within
divisions that that gets extremely
extremely complicated
um i don't know if i answered your
question what was it again well i was
trying to understand
um the nature
of the recruiting
of young people into this movement and
whether it's
covering whether basically if you were
a i'm trying to find a synonym for a
a punk because i don't want to demonize
you know ideological punks as it were
maybe i even identify with them but
if you were just a punk kid right who
didn't want to behave yourself because
you like
tearing [ __ ] up right yeah and then
somebody's flyering your high school
saying you know are you sick of
colonialism do you want to do something
important
right it's you know it's kind of it's an
analog for
you know the pitch that the military
might make to
capture you know young men who you know
are
itching to to you know
i don't know shoot up some baddies or
whatever so
that those people could be brought in
and effectively would be used
you know so i guess i'm seeing um
you have civilization right let's agree
that it's broken
right it's very productive but it's
broken and it's also
desperately unfair in many ways and so a
discussion i never properly hear
is are you better off in a broken
civilization that's very productive and
doesn't distribute stuff fairly
or would you be better off without that
civilization in something that fairly
distributed
a much less productive uh um
you know set of gains um you know if it
distributed them fairly
right and i think unfortunately the
situation that we're in is just
very very clear which is actually even
being unfairly treated
you are getting a tremendous number of
benefits from this civilization
and the only rational thing to do is to
try to make it fair
rather than to upend it in hopes of
creating something fair which will
undoubtedly be
really unproductive but nonetheless
there's some adult conversation to have
about what works what doesn't
what part of this is actually a racket
and what we might do about it and then
there's
what i would say is not an adult
conversation which is
let's tear this down because we've got
all kinds of ideas about what we might
do instead
right never mind that we don't agree on
them and then
uh within that thread
you've got adults who maybe have a
deeper
um insight into
you know some long-standing tradition of
anarchism right that's actually
ideological and they are recruiting
kids who are you know uh
troubled and so anyway you've got kind
of a mirror
inside of of the anarchist or the
insurrectionist
anarchist movement that has you know
would-be adults and uh you know mentees
mixing and i'm wondering how much of the
the violence and destruction you know at
some level
kids don't know stuff i'm sure you
didn't know stuff
when you know you were a young kid i can
say the same thing of myself
and it's you know it's natural to be
trying on all kinds of
viewpoints and perspectives at the point
that you are
you know firing explosives into
a federal building something else has
happened
and i'm i'm trying to understand how it
is
that kids who yes might be trying on the
idea that civilization is just
so broken that it can't be rescued but
should be trying it on as an abstraction
are actually succeeding in attacking
the structures of the adult world and
they are being taken
way too seriously by people like our
mayor here who has
you know been effectively coddling and
protecting them
even though they're threatening to tear
down uh something that all of us
including the protesters are depending
on
they enjoy it that's that's the part of
it that
is elusive is that they don't
they don't just enjoy it i would almost
say that there is
an addictive quality and
i think that's a word that i've been
looking for for a while
because what i realized in portland
after the win against the federal
government and the federal government
wasn't going to come out anymore at the
courthouse
i was there for those next days
and people were didn't know what to do
they were antsy you had a couple older
generational pacifist types on
megaphones
so that was very annoying so when august
6th they decide
we're just going to go out on our own
and attack this other precinct another
part of town and go through these other
neighborhoods that
to me was a signal that we just want to
keep doing this
that's all we just want to keep going
because there was no moment of okay
let's reflect we just had a big win
against the federal government
uh what do we what are we looking at
strategically philosophically
what discussions are we having it wasn't
that it was
the word i used was jonesing i said the
helmet heads
are jonesing right now because literally
i was walking up and down in front of
the courthouse
and they were they were hanging on the
fence peering over people were shooting
some fireworks
somebody burned an american flag there
was just nothing to do
you had all this pent up energy that now
they weren't coming out to play
the feds weren't coming out to play the
police weren't coming out nobody was
coming out well what now
what now so we just start burning stuff
that's what happened and then a couple
days later you go out and you burn stuff
somewhere else
and then you go through this
neighborhood so there is an addictive
quality to how this is being enjoyed by
the people who are partaking in it
that's
i think that's what that that's the most
accurate characterization
that i can i can
assess from dc from what i saw in dc to
portland and the san francisco bay area
i saw that same addictive quality it's
not everywhere
these these movements and these these
anti-fla antifa
atlanta was extreme was totally
different from what i saw
and again disclaimer after disclaimer
different
social movements in louisville it's very
denver's extremely diverse
you have marked actual marxists with
with a
hammer and sickle flags and i marched
next to a guy who had a
full arm tattoo of joseph stalin and
those guys are called tankies
the uh stalinists who who are statists
so so if you're an anarchist you're kind
of against the people who are the
statists
but as you said earlier you put those
divisions
behind you and that goes to that ann
arbor conference
one of the ohio's two brothers from ohio
that were
originally in the anti-racist action
they said it didn't matter
what you were when we had to come
together against a common cause the
white knights met skirt
these bonafide white supremacists it
didn't matter if you were a maoist
a stalinist or or what have you
we put all that aside and we work
together to fight the common
enemy and i think i think we've seen a
resurgence
under the administration of donald trump
is they identified that
as the common fascist enemy and so
everything was
put down as far as far as divisions and
banners
for the most part there's actually one
funny story in portland where
i saw a couple black bloc anarchists
kick out the revolutionary communists
from l.a
and they they were they were there with
their banner for two days
and this is like day 65 of the protest
and this group of youngsters are like
get out of here with your [ __ ] banner
and your [ __ ] website coming in here
day 65 we all know that rev com is
[ __ ] and they they chased them out
and said come back as individuals
come back as individuals yeah put your
band away come back as individuals
yes that's funny with the black block
which is this
obviously de-individuating methodology
yeah um yeah well this is this is
fascinating so i i must say um
i've thought a lot about the larping
aspect that there's a lot of
role-playing and gamesmanship and
i actually talked to a a federal officer
who described how the federal officers
had actually
war gamed out both sides of
their conflict and actually you know
he was amazingly humane you know it was
weird he was obviously
frustrated at you know having
projectiles launched at him every night
but he was also he felt protective
of uh the anarchists and and
felt that his you know he's like look
we could overrun these people and put
you know put down this uh
this attack any day of the week but we
can't do it without hurting them
and i'm going to feel a terrible sense
of loss if they get hurt
right so anyway i found that interesting
but he described
the war gaming where half the time they
had been on the antifa side
and then half the time they had played
the role of of officers and he described
how much fun it was on both sides
right and how the tactics had evolved
and
um in any case so the larping
i think there's something very deep here
and it is a kind of
you know high stakes larping
but addiction that's new to me and i
agree it resonates right away that
there's a sense
in which if an individual goes and
attacks
a federal courthouse they get arrested
and whatever dopamine rush they got is
then followed by
some terrible hell so it doesn't happen
a lot
but if a group flying a banner figures
out how to attack a courthouse night
after night and it's all very
spectacular and invigorating
right and you know just who the enemy is
it's those people you know dressed in
riot gear on the other side and you
don't need to worry
about the fact that they're human beings
and that they have families and that yes
some of them are bastards but some of
them are certainly not right
right because the fact is oh if they put
on that uniform they're
bastard by definition and they deserve
death by definition right
everything becomes very simple and if
you don't have to worry about what world
you're trying to build because obviously
the first job is just to destroy this
one
right well then that becomes very simple
too and so it
is rather a lot like a video game
in which there are assumptions at the
point you boot up the video game
there are assumptions about the world
that you have just stepped into
what tools you have at your disposal
what the limits of your behavior are
right and the point is it's go and it's
dopamine dopamine dopamine
and then at the point that you have to
put it away maybe you miss it
and in some sense we're watching this
play out in the streets and the hard
part to understand is not so much
why people do it and why they like it
the hard part to understand is why those
of us
who know that this is not leading
somewhere are tolerating it
this is the question that is hardest to
ask especially
as somebody who identifies i identify
myself on the left part of the political
spectrum and i have i have friends close
friends
who just won't talk to me right now you
know and it's hard you know i i
want to have real conversations about
this but
there is something significant about
where this is playing out the pacific
northwest
the the san francisco bay area
minneapolis washington dc
uh you know and those
four regions there's there's there has
to be
a way to look at that and talk about
that and and and figure it out and i
don't even
i can't even begin but one thing let me
let me say this when i was
in with one of the groups up by you they
were one of the youth groups they were
recording this is on
discord which is a a video game server
so of course
that's the other thing is when you're
using avatars this all starts online
your connections are not your face your
connection is some
comic book character or some graphic
novel
or or some historic whatever you're
identifying with you're presenting
yourself through that avatar
when you first hook up with these groups
in a lot of cases
certainly at the beginning uh and i was
there presenting myself you have to say
why you're radical what you think of
donald trump you know this kind of stuff
and
they vet you and one young woman said
i'm 15.
and my dad told me about this group and
[Music]
i thought well there you go if you have
not only
cover but not so it's not only cover
or support but it's actual approbation
from the older generation that you're
fighting
the good fight then you're coming in
saying hey this is my culture this is
who we are
and it gets it's there are larger
cultural questions that
that are worth addressing and i am not
even
remotely qualified to begin talking
about
but from what i've seen on the street
that if if young it's not just young
people oh here's an interesting
a very interesting point that hasn't
been talked about
michael reinel who shot and killed
jay danielson who was a member of
patriot prayer after
a maga caravan rally it was this caravan
rally important we all know
that descended into on the street
scrimmages
from larp what what we
have seen and known as larp scrimmage
scrimmages
there's been very little heavy artillery
or firearms it's just been
a bear spray mostly but on that
night he comes out and he shoots
and kills jay danielson his name michael
reinel was being carried on a banner in
sacramento this last weekend he's been
given martyrdom status not only that
when the news got back to the portland
protesters they applaud it
they cheered and they said i'm not i'm
not gonna you know
shed a tear here and they they cheered
cheered the death they cheered the
killing
the rhino was older he wasn't a young
man
but he was recently radicalized by
i buy instagram proof and this is
i looked at his instagram account and i
screenshotted some things but i was very
interested on
where what his posts look like
everything after may 30th
was all radical politics everything
before
may 30th was snowboarding
his family all this other stuff and you
you ask well is there a life event
that's connected you know
other people who who
probably you know know the personal side
i do not i'm just saying
that in the online presentation of
yourself
it's not just young people it can be
somebody of an older generation
that latches on and then presents
themselves in this social identity as
part of this group
and a part of this cause and when you
have a social
car a social agreement that breaches
generations
i think that's significant and if it's
also tied to other structures
in the in your local society then
then it it uh it becomes a phenomenon
and all right so i don't know that i
believe this but i
i think it's an idea worth wondering
about
um so i and
i won't speak for you but i won't be
surprised if you find yourself somewhere
similar
i find myself very much of the left
because i have a deep sense of what i
think
might be wrong what we might do better
what's unfair about the way things are
structured and i don't think it's a
small matter i think our
well-being depends on
upgrading the system so that it is
fairer and so that it's
built to tolerate the hazards of the
21st century
but i find that much of what almost all
of what i hear discussed on the left
is so clearly wrong backwards looking
uh unaware of underlying issues like
game
theory collective action problems things
like that
that although i find myself
in the neighborhood of the left because
i believe change is necessary
i find myself left cold by almost
everything discussed on the left
it's just not high enough quality to
constitute
a belief system however
what i'm watching is like a fractal
or maybe it's not like a fractal it's
like a um
[Music]
what would you i know what the
biological word is decline but
there's a gradation you've got people on
the very front line who are
launching uh ball bearings at police
officers with slingshots
right that's a potentially devastating
act and then you've got people behind
them who are ideologically
aligned dressed in black providing cover
but not actually
gonna launch a projectile at anyone and
you got people
behind them who are
um you know convinced that
uh that policing is so dangerous that
we'd be better off
without it and the point is you keep
stepping back and at some point
you know you're not uh an anarchist
but you're so frustrated at the genuine
problems that you see and their
persistence and our
unwillingness to look at them and
address them that you're willing to
donate
money to the cause right you're willing
to bail somebody out because they're
willing to launch
a ball bearing at a police officer or
something like that and so
what i'm trying to understand is how it
is
that a mayor my mayor
ends up hamstringing the police
such that violent criminals are allowed
to direct traffic they're allowed to
wake citizens up from their bed and
accuse them of things
in their own you know self-constructed
court in the street
all right it should be tremendously
popular
to shut down a movement that is
terrorizing
citizens and yet here in portland that's
not what we see we see people not only
tolerating this
but we see them actively supporting it
it's true that our
mayor beat the antifa aligned
challenger who faced him but apparently
uh he beat this challenger because there
was a third party in the race a write-in
candidate who robbed
the antifa mayoral candidate of enough
votes to return
wheeler to office so what i'm what i'm
trying to understand
is how it is that people could be
so foolish in the face of
a violent destructive movement
that does not like them right it's
willing to wake them up
with air horns and sirens and
you know it's willing to berate them on
their own front porch
that should be very unpopular and yet
somehow people expressing their will
through the system are supporting this
and
you know keeping it alive so am i seeing
it right
yeah it's continued idealism in this in
a sense
that okay you mentioned the bail fund
the bail fund's interesting in portland
because
there's over 1.3 million dollars but
when you do the math
of the contributions it breaks down to
40 contributions and this is what
people on the right don't understand and
i do have conversations when i cover
protests and i talk to people on the
right and i have to you know they always
bring up george
soros and you have to kind of explain
that these individual donations
who do they come from and i always say
it's fo it's
people like my folks you know it's it's
people who are on the left who are
who have are at a point in their life
where they have
they want to they see the righteousness
in the sense that
that they see the idealized
righteousness
they're not there they're not on twitter
they're not it's not being presented to
them on cnn it's not being presented to
them on msnbc
so they don't watch fox news so
if you have immediate diet
that supports it then it makes sense to
go along with it
and i still am looking for solutions and
i've turned i've not spoken out a lot
because i want the conversation to
i don't want to end up a sound bite on
fox news i want the conversation to go
towards
discussing progressive solutions
and i think they want that too
they want but they don't they don't know
what's being carried out because it
doesn't make it out of the local market
so when you say they want that too
you mean the people who are supposed to
do the donors yeah the liberal the
liberal donors
they don't see they they don't see what
gets out of portland
and minneapolis for example not only if
you're in northern california
not only do you not know that there was
a riot in sacramento
on saturday you also don't know that it
was coordinated
with a riot and saint paul at the uh
within hours both crowds
coordinated and organized to start with
the shields
go against maga and the proud boys then
get pushed back
then destroy all the cars that had you
know
and then claim victory the you don't
know that
because it wasn't reported now now
minneapolis it was reported more than
sacramento
but when it doesn't make it out of those
local markets
to cnn and this is where cable news and
national news
is you man i i'm a member of the media
for 17 years
i always doubted those especially those
from the libertarian right who are
telling me
that the media the media you know
curates the story and so on and so forth
and i said yeah yeah yeah
you know for 17 years i worked until i
was furloughed in may
and you don't understand that
wow if the connections aren't being put
forth in the national conversation then
they just stay locally
they don't they don't get out of dc and
connect with minneapolis
and portland and people aren't i don't
know anybody in the national news who's
written a story
connecting the tactics even that spread
virally through the internet essentially
since the end of may
nobody's nobody's talking about it and
so if you're one of those donors you
just don't know
you don't know what's going on on the
street
i think i figured it out believe it or
not yeah we got it i think
i say it with the i say it in jest but i
actually do think that there's something
really important here and that i finally
put
two and two together and gotten
something real close to four great
all right it's like this the
conscious mind is activated when things
don't add up
i'm not going to defend that statement
here i could but it's it's a biological
phenomenon and the
reason is that consciousness is not a
very good way of navigating things that
you're familiar with
it's the best tool when you're in
uncharted waters
in fact it's the only tool right so
consciousness i'm going to argue is
inconsistent
with consumer behavior
right and so my point would be an
advertising driven
model for news needs to keep you out of
your conscious mind
right you're not going to buy deodorant
if you're thinking real hard right or
you're not going to be persuaded to
switch deodorants or whatever it is
they're trying to convince you to do
right because that's your unconscious
mind that's you know persuaded by the
pretty model with the nice teeth and the
toothpaste or whatever
right as soon as you're conscious then
you're a whole different animal and the
fact is you're a skeptic
so my point is going to be that these
stories which do exactly what you've
described
and i've seen it so many times and you
know the fact is i became
uh enough of a news story for a while
that i watched these stories written
about me
and events that were central to my life
and so i could detect exactly what was
wrong with them
right i knew where these stories were
misleading people and there was very
little to be done about it
but the point is a publication
whose audience is left leaning and is
selling ad space to who
to whoever not only even if you would
read the story and pay attention to it
right what the advertisers need you to
do is not become conscious
and to the extent that a story that says
um you know that uh
left-wing protesters are behaving in an
authoritarian
anti-liberal fashion right that doesn't
quite add up and so
the point is in order to keep you out of
your conscious mind
to keep you in a buying mood or to keep
you compliant
you have to not be challenged and so it
isn't so much that people wouldn't read
stories
that uh challenge their belief system
but liberals aren't being told what
these people who are nominally on their
side are really doing
because it doesn't add up and to the
extent that it not adding up would cause
people to say wait
you know black lives matter of course
i'm on board with that black people have
faced terrible things in the u.s well
yes they have
that does not in any way suggest marxism
is the answer
right so to the extent that you have to
be confronted with the fact that
something that you believe is traveling
with something that you don't believe
right that would cause you to wake up
and so i'm i'm wondering
if what's going on is that the
advertising model
is causing publications and journalists
and every facet of the system to learn
the trick of not waking up the audience
right
telling them what they want to hear so
they don't suddenly realize
hey the world doesn't add up right these
people say they're on my team but
they're advocating for things i don't
like
um anyway does that resonate for you it
it does
i i do want to address one thing first
because i'm not sure of all of the
movements that i've talked about the
bugaloo
all the varieties of anti-fascia fascism
and anarchism
the thing i understand the least to be
quite honest
is black lives matter i do not know
where where it is like i know that i
supported it
and and still do in in principle
i don't know what this organization is
and what they're doing
i i know that now they've come out and
they're lobbying the incoming
administration
i do know that but i've been messaging
them since
june asking are you for or
against or do you even know what is
happening
on the street and that these tactics are
being executed
and then when i listen to podcasts of
the three women who started i
i i try to look for clues but i i'm not
quite sure that they are the same world
um as as that um as far as the conscious
oh oh but i do have to also mention the
marxist thing because
when i say i don't know what it is i'm
not sure where the marxist
connection comes in i do know that there
are physical marxists in denver
who identify as such and you do have
that identification
there is a social authoritarianism of
of these on the street movements but i'm
not
sure about the marxism thing because
that might i might my instinct is that
might be
another one of these tripping points um
but but we could get into that later as
far as the consumer
consumerism it's actually my dad who is
of this
donor generation that that
supports the causes much like i do
and he he copied he and my mom have been
copying my work since may and uh
um not without some resistance this has
been really
tough for there's been moments where are
you sure that this is
where you know can this wait
it's the big one can this wait
right till the elections the
inauguration to the to can it just wait
wait wait you know that that's the big
question but uh
i'm sorry i was just saying he said to
me one day
um we're out on the porch and um
and he said he's reading and talking and
he says this it's this consumerism it's
this mass consumerism i don't
i don't remember when i agreed to it
right
we never did we never did we were we
were transmuted from citizens and to
consumers and it's
absolutely diabolical in my opinion
um the kids and the kids know it the
kids know it
well this is where we all know it we all
know that something is desperately wrong
and so we you know we really ought to be
having a very rich conversation
about what the fundamental things that
are wrong are
it's likely to be small in number and
big in effect
but instead what we do is we all detect
that things are off we know that
civilization
is making us unhappy it's making us
physically unhealthy
it's making us psychologically unwell
it's making it so we don't know how to
interact with each other
and so people are in some sense lashing
out at the sense that things are just
way off
right and to that extent i resonate but
um to the extent that we are not going
to recognize you know you don't notice
the stuff that works
that's the thing about things that work
right is it's pretty seamless
right you don't notice all the
physiological stuff that works that's
modulating your temperature and keeping
it just right the ph of your blood all
of these things
they're seamless to you you only notice
when it goes wrong
and so civilization is humming along
it's putting us in danger it's doing
terrible things to us as individuals
but it is also feeding us in a way that
we do not
intuit because you know the food just
shows up at the supermarket
right it's so reliable you don't think
about it and
so the danger that we are being put in
by people who see only what's wrong and
therefore in
a mood just to simply destroy is
tremendous
and it would be you know some of them
are just crazy
right we we can't listen to people who
are hell-bent on destruction and would
be in any era no matter how good things
were
on the other hand there are a lot of
other people who are correctly
registering that things are not working
and have fallen in
with this ideology that thinks it knows
what the solution is
clearly doesn't i mean the way in which
these claims are wrong
is so you know it should take an
afternoon
to explain why it is that anarchism
cannot
work in the 21st century you know yeah
can it work in a group of
30 40 maybe 100 sure but is it gonna
work at a civilization scale of course
not it can't collective action problem
end of story so we need to be having
that conversation and we can't have it
because
even as we're becoming thinking people
we are being fed by something that wants
us in our consumer mindset
and that is uh it could hardly
could hardly be more dangerous i did
want to go back to one thing though
it's very interesting that you don't
resonate
with the idea that blm is marxist
right this strikes me so i will say
i have certainly encountered anarchists
for
many years now going back uh you know to
occupy
so um you know
that era but i've spent much more time
interacting with the black lives matter
side
of this current movement which is
something of a chimera
as you point out blm and antifa are not
inherently the same thing even though
antifa and anarchism appear to have very
deep anti-racist roots
right but these are two things that have
come together the marxism
it's one of these things especially if
you grew up
as a person on the left right you hear
people
ranting about marxism and it feels like
suddenly you've been teleported back
into the 50s
right and that people are hiding under
their desks worried about
you know the rooskies or whatever but
the fact is when you get
into what it is that's going on on the
blm
side you find the marxism is right there
now it's a new kind of marxism it's
racialized marxism but it is all about
redistribution right it's about
redistribution
on the basis of what is called equity
which the first time you hear equity you
think it has a lot to do with equality
turns out it's almost the opposite of
equality it is
equality of outcome but at a
racial and identity level and equality
of outcome is marxist and in fact uh
one of the founders of blm is on tape
saying that actually she's a trained
marxist so i looked that up and i think
it's significant
who she was talking to because she was
talking to a group of radicals
in baltimore it's a selective cut
so i i've questioned that cut a lot i've
tried to do
as much research as possible i would
love to see the whole thing
but her presenting that idea to to
to other radicals i thought i i didn't
have enough evidence because then i
later
heard her in conversation with one of
the other founders of black lives matter
sort of laughing about how they're
blanketly called
marxists because those women are very
capitalistic one of them's on a book
tour right now
you know so so it's there is this
disconnect
of entrepreneurial mostly a lot of black
women that i've seen that are involved
with the movement are very
entrepreneurial
and capitalistic and this idea of
marxism
uh as being an underlying current what i
do see though
i think i used a different word i think
i made up my own
identification for it which is the
social authoritarianism of it
which is that that you will and that's
what we see
when you're someone like me who's out
there on the street
is you're told to fall in line after
they bash the cars up they say they
the chant is what did you see i didn't
see [ __ ] what did you see i didn't see
[ __ ] and you know
that that idea that you're you're gonna
come in and you're buying
in or you're you know or not
it's it's a that's what i said is social
authoritarianism but
i don't know that the young kids or the
people who are out there
would even there are plenty on the
internet who
who laud
karl marx and you could see that all
over um
leftist twitter but i don't even know
that the people who are on twitter
sitting at home are the same
as the ones who are actively out in the
street
and so that's why i i gravitate away
from marxism as a label and it may be my
own bias because i've heard it so much
on right as a right-wing as a right-wing
talking point sure
but um what i'm trying to convey to you
is actually i don't care one way or the
other
what label we use and marxism you know
as i hear myself say it i do feel like
how on earth did i end up you know in
2020 talking about the hazard of
marxism in america on the other hand i
i lived this close up and this equity
stuff is about equality of outcome
but in order to define equality of
outcome so equality of outcome is a
preposterous and dangerous idea in and
of itself
and it is marxist yeah that's for sure
right
and in this case you've got a kind of
novel twist which is that who
whose well-being are we equalizing right
oh the races right and so
this intersectional stuff is very
academic it's uh it has a kind of
kernel of truth at its inception and
then
a lot of nonsense stacked on top of it
over decades
of work critical theory in all of its
forms
same way right there is a kernel of
truth
and then a whole lot of nonsense and
then
somehow it breaks into the mainstream
at the point donald trump is elected the
george floyd protests this
brings the anarchists in contact with
these
um let's call them functional marxists
they don't necessarily have to resonate
with marks
at all but the point is what they're
advocating even if they invented it
themselves
what they are advocating is equality
of outcome which requires massive
redistribution
and so um let's find a new term but
let's not fail to recognize
that what we've learned about marxism
and the reasons that it doesn't work and
the fact that it doesn't work
those lessons apply here and to the
extent that we need to have a
conversation
in which the huge majority of people
who resonate with black with black lives
matter right including me i resonate
with the slogan i believe
blacks have had a raw deal and i believe
it is time that we do something in fact
it is
overdue however if you sign up for the
banner that says black lives matter
because you know that there's a problem
for black people in the u.s and that it
needs a solution
right and then you end up through the
back door ending up with all of this
marxist redistributional stuff that's
game theoretically unstable
and a lethal hazard to the
competitiveness of any
organization that picks it up or any
nation that embraces it right
we're talking about a belief system
that is what will kill the goose that
lays the golden eggs when the real
question is
are the eggs distributed fairly right
so that's where we are we need to have
that question but i i think it's
absolutely fascinating that these two
things came together
and if you arrived at this discussion
through
the black lives matter uh critical
theory intersectionality route if that
was what caught your attention
then the anti-fascism anarchism
black bloc thing is a bit of a mystery
to you right you don't understand how
where it came from what it is
but if you arrived through that door
then blm is a bit of a paradox right
see blm seems like a totally rational
concept but the deeper you dig it's like
attacking the nuclear family and
all sorts of other stuff that you
wouldn't expect would be on the minds of
people
trying to you know solve a problem with
racial fairness
well and again i mean i don't i don't
know the nuclear family i've heard that
talking but i don't i don't understand
that to be quite honest um
uh is that where does that come from
though because again when i say i don't
understand black lives matter
i'm saying that the leadership has been
uh in my personal opinion absent in that
they haven't been connected to what's
going on in this street and so in that
absence
of active leadership in the anarchism
of the social justice movement
you have all these other things that
that come into place or fill that void
but uh i um i don't know i don't know
what you think in respect of that
yeah i'd be happy to tell you what i
know one thing i can tell you is that
um it was true early on
that when people were you know rah-rah
black lives matter
and i would say to them look i'm for
the idea black lives are undervalued
that's what that idea means to me
and i agree black lives are undervalued
in in
in the u.s and that needs to be fixed
however if you go to the website of the
organization
you will find that in signing up for
black lives matter you're signing up
to take a position against the state of
israel you're signing up to
you know fight against the nuclear
family so all of these things were
on their website i believe they've been
removed
because i think they took a lot of heat
but it's not like they were
repudiated they just
were removed because it was inconvenient
so anyway you might have to go to the
wayback machine or something like that
to find them but
here's why the nuclear family even comes
up here i suspect
one there is a problem in the black
community
with uh and people should not jump out
of their seats
there's a problem with too many people
being raised by a single parent
in general their mother right this is a
hazard because
human beings are very expensive and
difficult to raise so a two-parent
household this is a construction of
evolution that
allows the labor of raising a child to
be distributed and
the fact is unless you're very very
wealthy raising a child alone is not an
easy thing to do
right so anyway why is this happening in
uh in black america with such regularity
well i would argue it has a lot to do
with the fact that opportunity
is not evenly distributed it is lacking
in the black community this results in a
great deal more crime than would
otherwise
be committed by blacks which results in
a lot of incarceration which means
that there's an imbalance between the
number of men
in the community and the number of women
and what that does
is it undermines women in
it undermines their bargaining position
in
forming pair bonds right that is to say
because men are men because men can
reproduce without committing to anyone
um men are
wired to look for sexual opportunity
that does not require commitment
now when you have too few men in a
community because there's not enough
opportunity and because
men have been incarcerated in large
numbers
what that means is that the men who are
not incarcerated are in very high demand
because they're in very high demand they
end up having lots of choice and women
are in competition with each other very
intensely so
for the attention of men and so it's
very hard to get men to commit to a
single
partner when there are always lots of
options for them so in my opinion
that is the root of the single
parenthood crisis
that exists in black america the problem
though is that white society never tires
of uh portraying black culture as
defective
and that being the root cause of single
parenthood and so there's a sensitivity
amongst blacks about single parenthood
and a desire
to defend it and so here's where the
answer to your question comes
if you imagine that there's something
marvelous about the nuclear family
about a pair of parents raising
offspring then this
situation where you have a lot of single
parenthood
in the black community looks problematic
but if you don't have a choice then it's
the only mechanism
or it's the common mechanism to produce
offspring so there's a temptation to
regard
the nuclear family which by the way is
an invention
the nuclear family is not some
ancient structure it used to be that two
parents would end up raising children
but they would be embedded in a larger
kin group right you would have you know
you'd
be raising children in the same family
in the same village where you were born
your family would be around you there
were a lot of people to take some of the
burden from parenthood so in any case
in some sense there is reason to attack
the nuclear family as an
invention because it is an invention
right the idea that people would move
into some different city they would
partner up with one other person they
would raise children together that's a
broken system compared to
a larger kin group that raises children
but
that is not the same thing as an attack
on the nuclear family in other words
the pair bond is key to raising children
well right that pair bond would be
better off if it were embedded in a
larger family
but it is still better than a single
parent with respect to being able to
distribute the burden of raising
children so
in essence what has happened is because
there is
a sex ratio problem in the black
community
there is a single parent problem which
plays a role
in uh in dysfunction
and black lives matter has attacked
the nuclear family in some sense as
a uh a mechanism
for equalizing the playing field in
other words if
there's something broken about the
nuclear family and the problem isn't
single parents the problem is that
people are pairing off in other
communities then that attack in theory
is an equalizing force does that make
sense
yeah makes sense i wonder it has me
thinking about
all these alternative structures that i
hear just being around it
i haven't delved into the ideas
of you know of of communal
living they they talk a lot about mutual
aid
about you know who keeps us safe we keep
us safe
the social um
bonding in these protests is significant
i go back to sacramento again because
this is another example
when they beat up the couple one of the
surprising
events was then their own medics came in
to tend to the couple that was just
beaten
so you had your own criminal action
then you had your own medics come in you
had your own press to
deciding how to cover it favorably and
then you had your
own security with umbrellas policing
who get how things move along move along
you know you didn't see [ __ ] that kind
of thing and
so the idea that the social this new
social bonding replaces
whatever traditional ideas
we would otherwise gravitate towards i i
i guess i can i see it discussed
uh philosophically but i don't know if i
would
attach that just to one organization
like blm for example because you have so
many organizations
so sacramento antifa on their blog said
we had 25 organizations out this last
weekend that came together
that's in one action of a thousand plus
people on the streets of sacramento
so you know the the number of
different small groups that are at work
that are networked
is really quite quite astounding
um i wonder as i think of solutions
because from the beginning
i have always been insistent that i'm
not i'm not trying to
capitalize on on my work i'm trying to
think of an eye of these ideas
uh that that you you mentioned the
equality of outcome equality of
opportunity
i see is the antidote that is is missing
and i look at my the opportunities that
my parents generation
have and it's it's very clear part of my
family
um hails from uh the japanese-american
community
and to a point where some of them were
born in internment camps
so that community had everything taken
away from them
their land was even sold they could go
into the camps by the oppression of this
government
with only what they could carry but when
they came out
a lot of them went to the east coast
when they got back to the west coast
they faced prejudice there was still
equality of opportunity for that
generation
um in their experience
i want to just say in their experience i
have to qualify that uh
so much so that uh you know my my aunt
for example you know when she
had uh there were reparations made to
the japanese they got them in their ni
in the 90s by that time um
a lot of them own their own houses
already and that's because
going to college going to the uc system
like
um you know like my parents did like my
aunt did
uh it didn't you didn't come out of it
with overwhelming
student debt and you could own your own
house and there was a pathway to
homeownership
so i keep thinking of quality of
opportunity and a progressive capitalism
that doesn't rely on redistribution
but of substantive of subsidizing for
example
down payments of for home ownership
there are small pro
programs in denver and los angeles and
these are the kind
of opportunities that we need to fight
for
as a nation like we're fighting a war
because
what we're seeing was didn't come out of
the middle of nowhere
just two years ago my dad was up in the
bay area he was involved with these
lecture series talking about the work of
piketty from europe talking
an economist and and they're talking
about
i remember one of the speakers saying
when the rich get
historically when the rich get rich the
poor get poorer
and that opportunity to enter the middle
class gets
more and more narrow well what do the
people
down here do and his words were eerie
said they don't just sit there and see
they never have historically and so
the idea that opportunity uh
equality of opportunity can somehow
somehow get us out of this mess is at
the forefront of my mind and i hope
beyond the echo chambers and the and the
polarization because what we're also
dealing with is
a profit model that in our media
that runs off of our polarization
and if we are just seeing that
and we have those blinders on we can't
see where we agree
for example when i tweet about or or
post about equality of opportunity
and that my parents generation had a
much easier way into homeownership and
building
wealth and then therefore having that
wealth
excuse me to pass on to future
generations
when i talk about that conservatives
like it
just as much as as progressives do so
there are these meeting places but if we
don't understand
that everything that we're seeing on
i don't even use the term far left
anymore
because they're right here they're right
next to us
and they're right next to us because we
are them we're the ones who are giving
cover
when we don't talk about it we're the
ones who are supporting
tacitly or or otherwise by buying into
these
other ideas of struggle without actually
participating
but but clicking this like or that
we are here on the left seeing
identical mirrored
quote-unquote extremism to the right
people are
dis it's they are disenfranchised
they are they don't trust the
institutions whether it be
government or media and they are looking
for something else and that's why a
third
party and i came upon your work looking
at you know your unity push
there there might be opportunity here
in this disintegration and this this
sort of
cataclysmic year that we've had there
might be opportunity
in which people that we traditionally
think of
as our political adversaries on the
right and the left
aren't as different as we think and that
the most passionate have gravitated
towards these polls
and we have to figure out
when we let our passion eclipse our
reason
because if there's one theme that
i've seen since you know all year long
whether it was on the right or the left
if
if passions equip eclipse our ability to
discuss
about these matters reasonably we we
won't even notice where we agree
because it'll never even be brought up
we won't even have a chance to talk
about it
so you're absolutely right about this
and i've spent a lot of time
you know the irony of the the way i
was forced out of my college put me in
contact with a tremendous
number and variety of people on the
right
okay so i've been on the far left my
whole life but many of the people that i
interact with
i would argue are center-right and some
of them just simply
write but what i've learned
is that in fact in 2020
most of the people in fact all of the
reasonable people
agree on the basics right they agree on
the principles
that are the core of our society they
agree
that it is desirable to have opportunity
distributed as broadly
as possible they are not interested in
seeing
one race triumph over another these are
broadly held american values they
weren't always
but they are now and we don't recognize
this because as you point out we are
being induced into a kind of
polarization that makes
other people unhearable to us
the problem is so i i
take your example of the internment
camps
for japanese americans very seriously
and in fact i'll
tell you that my grandparents
had a set of planters in their house and
the story behind the planters was that a
japanese man had given them the planters
to take care of them as he
went to the camp i think he went to
manzanar and he was going to return for
them
afterwards and he never came back
presumably he did not survive
his uh his incarceration there
um if that's even the right term i'm not
sure but
in tournament internment yeah but it's
all euphemistic
right in any case um you know that that
story is important to me because you
know my parents my grandparents were
certainly understood to be egalitarians
who knew
that what was happening to their uh
their
japanese-american friends and family was
unconscionable
there was nothing they could do about it
but
[Music]
but in any case the fact is leaving the
camps
was certainly leaving the camps with
very little
was certainly a disadvantage but it was
not something that couldn't be overcome
given the amount of opportunity that
existed right if you had
uh the ability to access the market
there was
opportunity even though there was racism
against japanese people and in fact it
was very intense at that point because
of
what had happened during the war but
what i think we need to understand is
that for people on the right
they tend to see the fact that we all
technically have equal access to the
market
as equal opportunity and to an extent
it's true you can overcome a substantial
disadvantage
even in the form of racial injustice
uh if you know how to access
the market and so uh for japanese
americans after the war
um for members of the jewish diaspora
uh like me yes that it's it's enough it
doesn't have to be the access doesn't
have to be
perfectly equal the tools don't have to
be perfectly equal it's enough but for
two populations
there has been a persistent problem in
other words there are features
of the environment in which opportunity
is imagined to exist
that don't function and so i would argue
that for
black americans and for native americans
there has been a problem and it is very
hard to diagnose exactly how it
functions and it's certainly
true that there are many successful
people in both of those communities
but there is also a problem a persistent
problem
that results in um stagnation
economic stagnation and an inability to
access
opportunity so in some sense i think the
conversation
that we ought to be having is
utopianism is dangerous even if you
agree that equality of opportunity is
the goal you're never going to perfectly
achieve it right and anybody who thinks
that a system that doesn't perfectly
achieve it has to be torn down is
actually putting us in danger
we need to achieve it well enough that
people have
sufficient tools that they can work
their way
into a better life
for populations for whom that hasn't
worked we have to ask the question
what happened why and i would argue that
in the case of black americans and
and indian americans that we're dealing
with two
very unique origin stories right unique
origin stories
that have disrupted the cultural tools
that would allow access and we've also
had a different kind of racism in both
cases so
there is something to be discussed and
to the extent that i think a lot of us
intuit that
we are tempted to embrace anything
that seems to be demanding improvement
but the problem is when
the you know when black lives matter is
demanding improvement
in improvement in the form of
abolishing police and as dangerous as
many american neighborhoods are
there's no neighborhood in the u.s
that's so
uh made so dangerous by the police that
eliminating it is going to make them
better
even when policing is biased what you
don't see is all the crime that is
prevented because people know that if
they commit crime
bad things will happen to them so we
have to figure out how to address the
question
of where is opportunity
not reaching what are the mechanisms
that prevent it from reaching
and what might actually help right how
can we actually democratize opportunity
so it is as broadly distributed as
possible because
unless you're a corrupt son of a [ __ ]
right
even if you're a die-hard capitalist who
believes that the market is the solution
to everything
there is no argument that the ar the
market works better
when access to it is narrowed right if
you're a
libertarian capitalist then you want
opportunity as broadly distributed as
possible
and that's the question how broadly
distributed is opportunity and the
places that it doesn't reach how do we
get it there
well that would be ferguson from where i
saw where i was
uh in the last six months i mean the
ferguson connection
to 2014 is
is very um apparent in in the sense that
not only did movements come together
ferguson is where you had
black lives matter mobilize and folks
took buses to ferguson
and anarchists also insert and i qualify
it
not radicals across the spectrum but
also insurrectionists who used black
block techniques
were there as well and have documented
it um
so it's all it's all out there on the
internet but but i went to ferguson
this summer and um and i walked around
and it was an interesting
place choice to go because i wasn't
going there because it was activated i
was going there to see
what it was abstract in my mind i didn't
know what ferguson looked like i i know
what los angeles looks like i know what
san francisco looks like
but i didn't know what ferguson was
and so when i i the first place i found
was the uh the liquor store and i went
and talked to people outside and inside
the liquor store and
walked around and i there there's no
memorials
in in ferguson there's it's it's an
inner city neighborhood that
when you go from business to business
none of the businesses
are black owned and the community
is nearly entirely black that that i saw
and that i spoke with certainly
from business to business from the
liquor store of course
you know the chinese food joint uh the
cell phone store
the black beauty supply store
and you would think and i started
researching the black beauty industry
and you would think that that that
there'd be opportunity there
in the sense that you know it
i i read that the market share of black
owned businesses
in um the black
beauty industry is somewhere between six
and ten percent
in that that it it
everything on the exterior said to me
this well this place must be black owned
and it
it wasn't and and so when it comes to
business opportunity
and home ownership and
wealth and all those educational
programs
when it comes to financial literacy and
you know i i as a privileged kid i
didn't i couldn't figure out how to get
a credit card
when i was 20 to there's
and i could because i i've been i'd
finished college and i didn't have a job
and they said well you're not in college
anymore so we can't give you a credit
card
and i said what and they said well
you're unemployed you don't have
you're not you're looking for a job and
you're not in college anymore so we
can't give you a credit card
we could have given it to you when
you're in college and
that stuck with me in the sense that
well okay
if if if there are all these arbitrary
obstacles and then some that aren't and
then
if you're in a community that's that's
isolated from opportunity
i i have to imagine that it's even
even more difficult and
uh so the question becomes the ferguson
that i saw and walked through once i
walked
walked around and talked to people it
reminded me of
other inner cities all across the
country
so so opportunity as a whole
how can we increase that so that we so
that people have opportunity to
own businesses in the communities which
they live
because pride of ownership then extends
not only to your home
but to the businesses your surrounding
your neighborhood
everything and and again this is where
i don't use radicalism as a bad word we
have to radically
radically restore the opportunity that
was available for
past generations and the only way to do
that is education and
uh and at least coming up with programs
that are social programs that that
help subsidize and and promote
these uh growth and opportunity and i
don't know i'd be interested i'm
supposed to talk to somebody
who's familiar with the opportunity
zones under the outgoing administration
and how that has played out and i'd be
very curious because those were
census tracts that were identified you
know not by race but by
economics and so forth and i'd be very
interested to see
what has been going on and promoted in
as far as urban development in the last
uh
four years i'd be curious what what the
current status of those programs are
and how they could be built upon and
perhaps
there could be some sort of consensus on
what we need to do to restore that
opportunity for
this generation and future generation
yes i'd be very interested to see that
conversation happen and i'd be
especially keen on it
if it uh included
some voices from the
right i'm thinking in particular bob
woodson
and john wood jr both of whom are
friends of mine
and they have compelled me that the
traditional
view of the hazards to black america are
misunderstood
on the left at first i didn't know
i didn't know what they were telling me
but i over many conversations i've
learned
quite a bit and there's a lot to be said
i would say
for figuring out there's a traditional
divide between the focus on the right
on personal responsibility and the focus
on the left
of collective responsibility and it
seems to me that there is a very natural
interplay between these things that we
never spell out because of the
polarization
which is that civilization
has an obligation to make things
functional so that your personal
responsibility
is sufficient right so
your it is your responsibility to make
use of the opportunity
that you have but it is our collective
responsibility to make sure that you
have that opportunity
and that those two things have to travel
together and i think it's
it is exactly the right moment to be
having that conversation in fact it's
overdue
but i do think uh if we can get past you
know fighting each other in the street
over
cartoon visions of the future that
this is the place that we have to go i i
think even those people that are in the
street don't really understand how close
how close they are to each other uh
i have a new podcast that i'm doing
called un unblocked
and has double meaning obviously but uh
one of them's is
we've got to stop blocking each other
we're going to start listening to each
other so i'm
interviewing one activist from the the
left and then one activist from the
right and that's how i'm
starting it out is just alternating
between and we could
go up the chain differ chain in
different
or along the chain rather
as to to different social stratospheres
where people on one side of the
political spectrum and the other
actually agree i think it would be
fascinating because as i said the the
one organizer that i've spoken to who
considers himself
antifa when i talked to him
he even said a pox on both our houses
then
which of course is a reference to
shakespeare and that
that that they're trapped since 2016
aunt defend the proud boys
in this sort of psych cycle of violence
and nobody talks about how violence is
cyclical in the anarchist movement they
talk about diversity of tactics and the
violence
is not immoral but did you
think to maybe consider that it's
cyclical and that it's hard to get off
that train
once you start once this group is
fighting with this group openly on the
streets of
portland and sacramento that uh
that you might get caught up in it and
you might not realize
how your opponent and yourself might
agree
on certain things they're both they're
both against the drug war
you know they're both against um
uh they're i remember talking and being
really surprised by how many
how anti-authoritarian
they they both say they want to be
and on how many points of possibility
there are but when you're
too busy bear amazing each other and
hitting each other with shields because
you think the other is
represents something that the propaganda
has told you because
the propagandizing is just constant
and they just stay at each other's
throats and and
and they're not alone to say that it's
just the larpers in the street is wrong
it's us on our social media every day
taking sides and pointing the finger at
that person
and that that extreme example that we
would never be
yeah exactly i mean in fact i i'm always
pointing out this uh
report that emerged the hidden tribes
report
which reveals that there's something
like 67 of us in the middle that agree
on the basics
and um that you know we're not extreme
on uh most issues right
and this exactly mirrors my experience
traveling
between the left and the right and
talking to people and my feeling is
it's actually very simple in general
except for the fringes
we agree on almost everything
with respect to values what we disagree
on
is how close we are to a fair society
and what the ordering of the priorities
are in other words we agree on what the
priorities are but we don't agree on
whether
you know justice is more important or
liberty for example right but we
agree that they're on the list and it's
just a question of which one is the um
the top value
and we you know we do have real
disagreements many people look at
uh look at the us for example and they
say well
i faced disadvantage i did fine i know
lots of people like that
you know it's fair and if you're unable
to
get out of poverty for example that's
that's on you because the opportunity is
clearly there
and then others regard the problems as
extremely pernicious
and uh structural and you know
that's a hard conversation to have but
it's a lot easier than imagining that
the person on the other side of that
discussion
is you know inherently a racist
right or inherently a fascist or
any of these things so um yes if we can
get out of the narrative that we have
been talked into
and into a discussion about all right
where actually are we you know
how much have we achieved how much
remains to be achieved
and you know what is the safest
and best route there the opportunity
for us to do better and to solve the
problems that are real
is spectacular though i worry we won't
do it because we're
uh we're all sucked into this narrative
in which uh the boogeyman is right
around the corner
yeah i i think if we we have to look at
some of the forces that are propagating
that idea though and that's why i've
been out on the streets
in not shying away even online
to the attacks because like you
when new york times piece came out there
was an organized
a couple of groups one of them was a
radical
bay area group that has a very high
profile
publication they also have a radio show
and then
another group was really a global
anarchist
publication and even like the
trotskyists in michigan
uh came out and uh there's one more
well well the minneapolis uh group that
is very labor-oriented
the you know the iww and the wobblies
also
have a very pro radical insurrectionist
uh identity
identify identification in some sense uh
in some places like minneapolis um
so so i had a couple wobblies contact me
personally and say you're you're you
know you're messing things up and this
and that
and some of them were polite some of
them weren't uh but
but it all sprung up because first of
all you're not allowed to talk to this
it's a little protectionist in the sense
that if you're in high school and you
really like this band and that's your
subculture
and and you identify with that and then
some like
normie tries to talk about it it's it's
[ __ ] outrageous and and you
and you're gonna you're gonna erupt
right just fully you're going to erupt
and do everything you can to
point out how unqualified this person is
to talk about this
or even think about it but so a lot of
that
that uprising that internet uprising
when you try to have these conversations
it it has
a pattern to it and what i noticed was
these publications
talked about me and made follow
a whole list and threads of false
assertions
and character assassination because i
had reached out
to try to interview this is around
september 26th the proud
after the michael rhino and and
um jay danielson after both of them uh
died in
in these conflicts and so forth uh there
was this big
proud boys rally and i think there was
even a state of emergency that was
declared i was
i was there i went to both rallies under
dressed different
for for each of course but uh
but that i had interviewed and reached
out to interview
the chairman of the proud boys was uh
it was just blasted everywhere and then
it was this
and that i had retweeted something that
tim poole
said and it but it was tim poole was
saying that the president
should have said [ __ ] all white
supremacists
and i thought that was a funny thing and
i was like i retweeted it
and then and they're like he retweeted
twin tim poole he's all right
um and they just came after me it was a
rabid crowd i said well but he i
i first of all i don't follow this guy
that much anyway
but then he was saying [ __ ] all white
supremacists and
i can't it makes it makes no sense
there's no logic there's no logic to the
attacks but they will
dig and this is what i was surprised by
is
i they dug really deep because i used to
do comedy
um under my uh my nickname is kenji and
i
i was part of the new york comedy scene
but they found all this stuff from
you know another part of my life and
tried to screenshot
one sketch to make it look like it was
racist even though it wasn't
even though all my work was progressive
uh from that time i i did
i had to actually fight the alt-right
and
neo-nazis who came after a video that i
did that was on the view
it was socially progressive whoopi
goldberg introduced it
and it was a parody of a parrot it was a
parody of this cheerios commercial
which got attacked these alt-right
trolls attacked it because it had a a
bi uh racial couple um the young girl
pours cheerios on her debt they say it's
heart healthy and she pours the cheerios
on her dad's
heart and he's black and the mother is
white
and the all right just went bananas this
was several years ago i don't even think
they were called the alt-right then but
they were these neo-nazis that came out
of nowhere
and they were bashing me and so i i was
used to dealing
with i had been through the wringer with
the right coming after me because
our version of it it was a friend a
friend of mine who's a comic who's a
black woman
who was on on the on the couch at the
end and
so that it was a lesbian couple
uh infuriated them even more and
she turns the camera and says eat it
haters or
huffington post loved it and wrote about
it so so
i'm used to being on the the progressive
social side of this and then having the
right come after me
and it was very strange for the tables
to be turned
and for people to be saying trying to
paint me
as alt-right because what happens is
they they issue the
attack maybe at night they come at night
and if you're not looking at your
twitter well you've been blocked so you
can't see the initial post that's been
made out of it
defaming you because they make the post
defaming you and they block you
so all these people are talking about
you that you don't know
then you wake up the next morning and
look at your name if
you know you're narcissistic enough to
do so
and and you see that that uh
your it's gone from you were being
talked about is alt-right
in the original article then you're a
white supremacist
all of a sudden by the morning you're a
neo-nazi
and someone's calling me a neo-nazi and
i'm looking at this going
and you know the new york times reporter
wasn't was was
was she's like i've never seen anything
like this you know and she was
extremely nervous about how it was going
because they were calling for her to be
fired and this and that
and you you don't know what you're
talking about and it's just
and it's all based on hysteria and
harnessing hysteria
and being able to dr direct that
harnessed hysteria
at a certain person um and if you don't
engage
i think it gets worse yeah well they
they're doing what i would call driving
your costs
and so the idea is if you can punish
somebody it doesn't matter that the
accusations make no
sense right if you can drive them crazy
if you can cause other people to assume
there must be some i mean
okay they're calling you a neo-nazi
maybe you're not really a neo-nazi but
surely there's something wrong with you
right if that's the accusation then
you know clearly or something um if they
can make
life hell on the reporter who would dare
report the story
then the point is the stories don't
exist
the next story that would be written
doesn't get written the next person who
would
say what they know doesn't show up and
so
what it does is it creates this false
appearance of
consensus because the only voices are
those that are sticking to the narrative
and anytime you look for somebody who
tries to explain what doesn't add up
about the narrative
um what you find is accusations that you
have no way of evaluating
you know right like tim poole is of the
alt-right are you [ __ ] kidding me
right that's that's a bizarre accusation
um so anyway
part of what's going on is that the
narrative is artificially clean
because anybody who strays from it is
punished
to the extent that what we find is just
you know no variation in belief
it's it's a flex too because
it doesn't go unnoticed these these
publications
so this is my challenge if you're the
daily beast and you're the huffington
post
if you're the daily beast and you
printed back in 2017
that antifa is is problematic if you're
the washington post
what are you afraid of why aren't you
covering these stories
from a journalistic
point of view of just what's happening
on the street
are you that are the is does that flex
scare you so much
that that you're going to be thrown to
the walls
well i don't understand the problem is
you know the washington post seems like
a thing but it's made up of people
right and those people have jobs and
they have families to feed and they
don't want to have to find health
insurance on their own and all of these
things and so
the very fact that if you show
independence of thought you may have
thousands of emails arrive at your boss
you know telling them that you've
misbehaved or that you know
10 years ago you said something that was
uh suspect in one way or another the
problem is
that hassle the fact that your boss may
be concerned they will come after them
next
and may decide to fire you because
because they don't know how to defend
you means that
in effect these institutions get
captured by
perspectives that are willing to invest
in a punishment
and when we look at the washington post
and we say well
you're a newspaper surely you're
interested in reporting the news
and the answer is uh they are a complex
phenomenon that has all kinds of
influences and
the news is what they say they're about
but how it functions on the inside is
quite different well i've been pitching
to a lot of these organizations since
june uh as a journalist it's just
something you do
and then i died off for a while because
i realize there was a point i realized
okay this story is way bigger than what
i know
back in june for sure but after six
months of
really staying on it um seven days a
week uh
i i think i have a better idea um
especially being on the streets
but the so the question is how do you
get the people who are
in these institutions to appreciate or
understand
that what they're printing is divorced
from what's on the street
and it does have to be from the left
from
i've gotten offers from the right you
know
to publish or to to appear and this this
kind of thing
but we do need to talk to our
ideological sort of herd as it were in
uh and address so i think it does have
to be
somebody somebody like the huffington
post that does
write seriously about ethno nationalists
well if you're serious about ethno
nationalists
and you've published something that's so
serious about
ethno-nationalist that some of the
antifa groups are even retweeting it
then you must be serious enough to make
distinctions right i mean technically
you should be able to to make a
distinction between the
ethno-nationalists
and maga normie folks that are getting
you know they're getting punched out and
and the proud boys which is another
level of maga but not the ethno
nationalists
so i'd love to see that work i have my
doubts because all of the left-leaning
publications
seem particularly prone to having
narrative
enforced on them and i agree with you
that there there has to be um
those of us on the left who are
reasonable and are not buying this
nonsense
have to find our voice so in some sense
it's
odd but right leaning publications
have been welcoming of left
of center authors to describe this and
the problem is
if it's published in the wall street
journal you know or something like that
it is very easily dismissed right
because it's imagined to be right of
center and then you having written for
them
are imagined to be right of center but
um
the the key is again this vast group in
the middle
that agrees on the basics right we have
to stop thinking of each other as oh
that's on the
left i'm going to discount it or that's
on the right i'm not going to believe it
and we have to recognize that that
conversation
even those of us who come from one side
or the other we have to meet in the
middle and have that conversation
and the question about what venues will
allow it is unfortunately
um one with not a lot of answers most
venues are afraid of one constituency or
another
yeah and i i just don't know where this
goes
because already we're able to curate
what we want in our news too easily
we're not challenged at all
but even on personal connections with
people
on facebook for example even in a closed
group of 500 friends or what have you if
they're still they don't feel like
conversations can happen
well then what when one group
goes through an exodus and says well
we're going to go to this other platform
well how's that going to help us see
right how are we going to get anywhere
then we're going to have echo chambers
that are so
narrow and consensual
that we're going to start losing touch
even more
my life some of the important changes in
my life this year
you know going to ferguson was
eye-opening but also going to tulsa was
tulsa
i thought i was going to find white
supremacists
i came into this story when i witnessed
actions and we haven't talked about it
much but in santa monica that were
coordinated in los angeles
and the fir we didn't even oh we forgot
to talk about the videos and stuff that
i had sent
but uh but the patterns
and and the tactics that were being used
as i pursued them
i did i did realize
that yes there's genuinely stuff
happening
on the left and i recognize techniques
and there's a very
explicit video from los angeles of a
police car being
now i'll put that up on publicreport.org
video i'll have a couple of these videos
and and
in that you see the black block
practitioners working as a team with
with skateboards to bust out the windows
pour in lighter fluid
and it's a black guy that realizes this
and he comes home and he's like oh my
god this stuff was
was was he says stage but i think he
means coordinated it was it was all
coordinated
um in other words staged not
to apply that it's you know some sort of
it's not it's not phony but it was
plural yeah it's not phony but it was
planned
exactly uh and you see
that they're doing black bloc this is on
may the 30th in los angeles in front of
cbs
studios on fairfax avenue uh in the
torching of the police cars
and actually a a friend of mine
a photo came across my feed where i saw
my friend standing on that police car
burn out and i thought wait a second
that doesn't compute and it's just
because i know that friend
and i know he didn't burn it so it was
it was it did become after the fact
after it was coordinated it became a
staged event in the sense that you could
stand on the police car with your your
fist up and get a self or a
picture and then it would enter your
social media feed so all this stuff
played out in an in a viral fashion
a law the one term that was used in a
rupture study was
virally enhanced mobs that through
hashtags
that became trending on twitter certain
techniques could be shared from
organization to organization
and that's why we had so much symmetry
much like we just had last week between
saint paul and sacramento that
has been going on month after month
after month without much
light being shined on it because nobody
is even willing to really have a
conversation about it
and washington dc is going to be
interesting not just on december 12th
but on inauguration day because
inauguration day is the traditional
anarchist protest day
where anarchists always protest i think
they they didn't
obama's first year but nationwide
the anarchists have always i don't know
how much i should be
advocating that but i i'm just saying
that
it doesn't end there there's always a
new date whether it's thanksgiving and
you're tearing down george washington
and portland and minneapolis at the same
time
there's always going to be another date
or excuse for this
mod mobilization until we address
the ailments in a sufficient radical
enough way of our society to make make
some serious changes i think that's
their point
and they certainly haven't been shy
about making
well i i disagree with you a little bit
um i don't think that there is anything
that we could do
that would satisfy the
hardcore anarchists and i realize you
know
i don't want to paint them all with one
brush but i believe that the demands are
so preposterous
that you know effectively civilization
would have to fall
in order for them to recognize that they
were incorrect
right abolish all police abolish all
prisons total abolition
is the slogan of the that you're
referring to
right yeah it is and the point is they
actually believe it
and it's actually crazy and we can't
afford
to test it out but what that means
is that we are in effect stuck
with this movement behaving in this way
until we learn how to say no to it and i
think that's
really from my perspective that's the
key insight
right that in effect you can't bend over
backwards far enough as a mayor or a
police chief
in order to satisfy this movement and in
light of that that
means you're going to pay the price of
cracking down to them on them
at some point and you're either going to
do it
before they've done a tremendous amount
of damage or after
and so as much as you know i
i don't love seeing a police crackdown
but if people are
violating the law and demonizing other
citizens and
you know waking them up in the middle of
the night and harassing and intimidating
and threatening
and harming then they have to be dealt
with that's just
simply the nature of the societal
agreement that we share
yeah and the societal agreement is
uh extends beyond law enforcement i i'm
thinking and
one theme that's come back is is the
consensus
gives it cover there's a reason that
portland the bay area
and you know minneapolis if there's
enough consensus in the mainstream to
give it cover
then it will keep going it will keep
happening if you're not
even talking about it or you're too
afraid to talk about it or publish
conversations
because of the repercussions that you
imagine to be out there
then that's cover it means that the
bullying is working it means that the
the suppression the umbrella is in our
face
the umbrella is in all of our face in
some of these cities
as it continues week after week saturday
after saturday
and in some cities like yours they don't
just pick one day
no it's every day it's everyday everyday
anti-fascist is
is one of the slogans that you'll see in
portland
you know printed up out about
and it's i'm glad that
we're talking about it you know of
course i'm nervous more
nervous in the sense that uh there's
you have energy coming at you from all
directions you know
and if your friends tell you not to not
to say anything
that's that's equally as worrisome as if
they if your enemies tell you not to say
anything
yeah it's or perceived enemies i should
say no unfortunately i think there's a
lot to fear
and uh i think
it is important that we
not give into that fear because the
danger
of us not discussing it is so profound
you know it is it is a very it is a
small
movement but it is powerful by virtue of
the way
that it intimidates um and stigmatizes
so we have to talk about it the danger
is real i'm not happy about it
i'm sure you're not happy about it but
uh
you know your courage is is an important
part of this story
well i i am i think that
from the beginning i've wanted to engage
as well and
i've tried to have conversations real
conversations
because just like you said if a
publication
is made up of individuals and so forth
well
so are each of these little
organizations they're
all individual people who have friends
of different parts of the social
stratosphere i would think and so
if we talk about it as a society you get
enough critical mass conversation going
that it doesn't become so
addictive and uh
subversive you if you shine a light on
on something and have a discussion about
it an honest discussion
then the lie doesn't get to win and
right now the lie is winning
and i've felt that for for a long time
that if we talk
and discuss and engage each other in
good faith
that that will open the door to
possibility because what is so
transparent is that those who want to
control the conversation
won't engage in good faith they'll only
hit you with ad hominem attacks on your
character
and made up you know well don't talk to
this person because he talked to that
person
or that person is a known person to have
associated with that person who
associates with that person
the logic is is infinitely uh
frustrated and and transparently
sort of flexible it's inconsistent
and uh it is unendingly punitive
and they know it exactly it's unendingly
punitive
and who can really live in that
environment
when you the next person to be rope
speared could be you
yep you know well let me just say um i
would be open
to having this conversation with you
and one or more members of
the anarchist the insurrectionist
anarchists or
antifa or both um and that might be
worth doing
there might be uh some real value in
having these perspectives uh meet on one
screen
yeah that actually would be interesting
i you know i had reached out
to uh both sides in a similar sort of
vein i'd
i had been talking to
and was blasted for talking to antifa
and the proud boys at the same time to
try to get them to talk
which was uh this is that's a that was
that's a tall order i mean
uh because once one of them talks to
another then
there it would have it always has to be
somebody that
has enough armor it's almost why i said
the huffington post
should just walk in and cover the stuff
they have enough armor they've done
enough on white
ethno-nationalists nobody's going to
believe them that the
huffington post is is white supremacist
you know
you know what i mean so that's why i
keep saying you guys this is this is
something you can do
you can you can help bring conversation
and discussion about
about what's going on but but equally as
is important is i think that
um what i would provide
is it's tricky with
with the antiphon anarchists they only
go to their trusted sources
to those that don't don't push them
where
and if they are somebody who's going to
do that they're going to get pushed back
they're going to get
blasted oh they will be they will be
punished from within
they will be punished from within so it
really is
up to them in the sense that and i
thought it was going to be after the
election i thought well the election's
gonna happen
you know and there will be this moment
where these movements will
uh once you don't have trump then your
enemy is gone
and then and then what are you gonna are
you gonna
mount an insurrection against joe biden
yes they will just
they will they will but it's it's not
going to get the same public
no it will cover an animus the public
will suddenly understand what it doesn't
understand now which was that uh trump
was a marvelous excuse
right that trump uh played the cartoon
villain
very effectively and that that took a
movement that already existed
and uh gave it a narrative that
sort of loosely added up to to john q
public
but this wasn't about trump
i think i've heard plenty from
inside these movements uh that
they hate biden equally as much
and that they intend to continue and so
all of those who thought okay
you know in part we have to elect joe
biden in order
to you know to put an end to these
violent movements in the street um they
just they were suckered
yeah well you know i i i did because i
wanted
a certain kind of pacification in our
um i still am idealistic that we can
talk to each other
and and the rhetoric our political
rhetoric can
in the mainstream certainly i hope that
switch from trump to biden will at least
provide that and again
the reason that the stuff in the streets
isn't talked about is because the people
that are off the streets
think that they're aligned in a certain
way
and they're not it's it's when you keep
trying to sort of
get through to people is that this is
something else this is something else
that has been
brewing for a long time and it's the
anti-globalization anti-capitalism stuff
but it's also the
anti-racist stuff and a myriad of
different groups who are
involved but unified in the sense that
if you're not with us then you're going
to
you're going to fall you're the enemy
yes well i think the irony
here is that um
[Music]
yes you can have all of these things
that you oppose
you know racism fascism whatever it is
that these people are
marching against the problem the reason
that this stuff resonates
the dysfunction actually comes from the
corruption
and the corruption is you know
at the heart of the modern democratic
party
and it is clearly at the heart of this
emerging
biden administration so you know the one
thing we are not talking about
is the capture of our governance
structures and the fact that it has made
them
dysfunctional and it has created this
massive wave of frustration
that is now being misdirected at all
kinds of uh
either
[Music]
exaggerated enemies or fictional enemies
or whatever it may be
but i i'm certainly looking forward to
the day when we actually start talking
about what really isn't right and what
really isn't right
is a um a corrupt political structure
that creates a tremendous amount of rent
seeking
and hoards opportunity and you know
that may sound like a boring enemy it's
not you know it doesn't feel as good to
fight corruption as it does to
fight nazis but you know the corruption
is real
and and you know this is why engage is
also
important it's important to engage with
with people and young people that are
disaffected and engage across the
spectrum
really and that's to have those
conversations and
would be great uh if you engage
you realize that i think that a lot of
people who are on the streets would
agree with you on that
on the right and the left the people who
are
uh protesting you know stop the steal
you know regardless of what you think
about
how that came about and so forth they're
just they're dissatisfied with something
in our government they don't trust uh
our political system and structures and
that's the same yep not different that's
the same
with it with the folks that are donning
black and i think you're going to see
those tactics
start to transmorph onto the other side
i agree there is something there's
always been something uh
bizarrely similar they dress very
differently
but the dyed and the wool libertarians
and the died in the wool anarchists
believe something very similar and
yeah um you know yes there's a there's a
much larger conversation to be had and
one that i hope will
will emerge maybe in part in response to
uh to this discussion
i hope so i hope so all right yeah this
has been great uh
let's see so jeremy lee quinn where can
people find you
[Music]
publicreport.org and there'll be links
there to um my podcast which is called
unblocked podcast and links to you know
twitter and all of that
and all of the visual evidence since may
all right is it laid out excellent well
i really appreciate your courage in
speaking about this
i know that uh you know i'm concerned
about what might come of it and i'm sure
you are but
uh we have to continue to talk about it
irrespective of
what comes back and i look forward to
checking in with you
as the story develops and maybe who
knows someone will contact one or both
of us
and be interested in having a
conversation in which we can hear how
things sound
um from the antifa anarchist perspective
hey the more conversations the better
excellent
all right be well everyone
[Music]
you